los combates en esta guerra de ucrania
se centran en la zona norte de kiev el
alcalde de irving una localidad muy
cercana a la capital la zona noroeste ha
informado de que el pueblo está libre
ahora de las tropas rusas pero pide a
los vecinos que no se acercan que no
intenten volver porque todavía hay duros
enfrentamientos el resto de los ataques
se concentran en la zona este y sur del
país en la región del donbass donde
están las repúblicas autoproclamadas de
dones y lugares pero también en zonas
que no habían sido ocupadas en el 2014
por los pro rusos en algunas ciudades
como crema toros también en localidades
como jarquín y mariupol hoy el
presidente de ucrania ha pedido que se
evacúe de forma inmediata y urgente a
todas las personas que estén en mariupol
la ciudad está arrasada pero lo cierto
es que no hay corredores humanitarios y
los ciudadanos tienen que jugarse la
vida cada vez que intentan cruzar esos
checkpoints que son constantemente
atacados por el ejército ruso